when you see a girl like you with bobby
and i love bobby and bobby's probably
one of my
50 probably 40 favorite people i would
bet 30.
30 top 30. but you s you think bobby is
more
prone to death i think then if i saw you
with like a big
six foot guy that guy seems like oh he's
gonna live forever so
bobby there's not in a bad way you know
i know i'm sure bobby's gonna look for a
long time
but you just see him as being like oh
anything could happen he
you know he drives and plays games he
just he puts himself in dangerous ways
so i think
then there's allows a little more room
for
who is going to care for this woman if
something ever happened to him
and not in a bad way but if and so it's
out of love i think that you look and
say okay
whereas if i saw you with some guy like
bill clinton like a young bill clinton
or something
then i think i would be like oh man you
know
even after he dies he'll still be able
to take care of her well i think that
well i don't know if ghost bobby could
hold you down is what i'm saying
uh i don't know can somebody help me out
here
i think bobby would haunt this out
of both of us yeah that's
true i mean if you're he
i don't know what you're trying to say
theo but you're saying
are you are you in line to catch me
should he die
are you the man to take care of this
woman and
this damsel in distress what is this
like is this a proposal
no i i this is what i wanted to actually
um hash out with you
okay for some reason i get a barrage of
messages
okay what does barrage mean that's
french isn't it barrage it could be
just always messages pertaining or
accusatory messages thinking that you
and i are in some sort of
um that you're my side piece that you're
my second
and i don't know where that comes from
because i don't feel like we've ever
talked about it on our podcast or have
we
i have never said anything like that i
mean i don't know if they
do you feel like there's any attraction
between us or no i
i personally don't think so
but i like you a lot so i said do you
feel like there is i don't mean that in
a bad way
okay here let me try to break this down
in like a really transparent way i want
to be honest
um there are people that i walk past
that i feel like an instant like
chemistry with
i'm not threatened by that feeling at
all i just kind of like clock it
and then you know it's it's it validates
that i'm human
um i do have it with certain people in
his life but not you
okay okay um you play a sad sound
do you have any sad sounds
because you you feel more like family
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
know louisiana's not is it
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what bobby
always says hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one